en algún vídeo previo teníamos una
figura como esté sentado en un hexágono
no recuerdo bien y lo que tenemos que
hacer es calcular los ángulos externos
de esta figura así que nombraremos a
este ángulo a este ángulo b c d ye y lo
que hicimos fue decir bueno el ángulo a
va a ser 180 grados
menos el ángulo suplementario a hicimos
eso para todos los ángulos interiores y
calculamos a través de dividir el
polígono por triángulos cuál era la suma
de los ángulos interiores de dicho
político y así podemos calcular cuál era
la suma de los ángulos externos pero un
proceso un tanto complicado lo que
queremos hacer en este vídeo es mostrar
un proceso elegante y simple para hacer
este cálculo exteriores ángulos
exteriores mejor dicho y de hecho
funciona para cualquier polígono convexo
cuando quieres calcular las sumas
ángulos exteriores y la manera como lo
vamos a abordar es re dibujando los
amplios así es que permite dibujar estos
ángulos
así que dibujamos nuevamente este ángulo
a la medida de este ángulo está déjame
dibujar el ángulo por acá este ángulo va
a tener una medida de a
ahora déjame dibujar el ángulo b ángulo
y la manera de hacerlo es lo va a
dibujar adyacente a esto lo podemos
pensar de la siguiente manera si esta
línea la ponemos aquí
entonces lo que tenemos es una línea
paralela que este es el ángulo b pues
esta es una línea transversal y estos
ángulos son ángulos correspondientes
poder de la siguiente manera es algo de
lo que me da es también sino que me de
ángulo vez y vamos a hacerlo también
ahora para el ángulo ce trazamos
entonces una línea paralela y este
ángulo también s
de aquí también este ángulo también es
debe saber algo así y eso podemos
hacerlo también aquí para de caminar a
otro color para que resalte esto podemos
dibujar a tejas y lo puedes mover aquí y
aquí estaría de o podemos ver si hacia
acá aquí estaría el ángulo de entonces
son paralelas y entonces tenemos d en
todos estos lugares y también podemos
poner de entonces aquí
así es que esta línea es paralela a esta
esta esta tenemos ángulo d finalmente
hagamos el ángulo ángulo en esta línea
la ponemos paralela y aquí también
tenemos el ángulo ay o aquí mismo
también tenemos el ángulo y cuando lo
vemos dibujado así sumamos los ángulos a
b c d y e nos damos cuenta que le
estamos dando la vuelta completa al
círculo alquier manera no importa si
vamos en sentido a las manecillas del
reloj o en sentido contrario a las
manecillas reloj
estaremos dándole una vuelta completa al
círculo de tal manera que si sumamos los
ángulos a más de hace más de una c esto
es igual a 360 grados
esto funciona para cualquier polígono
convexo cuando digo polígono convexo
quiero decir aquel que no se dobla hacia
adentro vamos a lo que me refiero va a
funcionar para cualquier polígono y no
quiero decir regular regular quiere
decir que tiene el mismo número de
ángulos y de la no va a funcionar para
cualquier polígono que no está apoyado
apoyado hacia adentro este es un
polígono convexo este es un polígono
convexo y aquí tenemos un polígono con
acá déjame dibujar este es un polígono
cóncavo un polígono cóncavo
tratando excel mismo nueve lados estos
lados que están apoyados checar si tengo
el mismo número de lados
veamos
este este este este
y su lado además existe un lado más unos
1 2 3 4 5 6 lados 123456 lados tenemos
aquí un polígono cóncavo perdón
polígono convexo mientras que aquí
tenemos un polígono con camps y la
manera recordarles que aquí tenemos una
dobla dura una abolladura hacia adentro
del polígono así que lo que hemos hecho
aplica para cualquier polígono convexo y
convexos y una disculpa si me he
confundido con cóncavo
así es que veamos el proceso nuevamente
si tomas este ángulo de aquí se los
sumas a este ángulo de acá a este otro
ángulo a este ángulo aquí a este ángulo
de acá finalmente este ángulo los sumas
ex ángulos las traerlas suman los
ángulos externos y no estoy diciendo que
éstos son iguales pongamos berdeak y
algún otro color aquí y no tienen que
ser necesariamente los mismos ángulos
pero al ponerlos así te darás cuenta que
da la vuelta al círculo y suman
finalmente 360 grados